The dilemma is always: do you make an ending that that's tidy and pat
so that the risk of having it be not
realistic—because tidy, pat endings, you
know, they're satisfying, but it's not
whatever really happens, right? Or do
you have it be a little looser, in the way that real life is, at the risk
of having it seem too open-ended? So I've kind of done both.
In a few of my books, I've gone to
some lengths to architect big,
complicated endings that all kind of
stick the landing. And in other cases I
haven't done so as much.
KEVIN KELLY: On the internet there was a joke that if they
had given you the task of writing the
last episodes of Game of Thrones there
would be two more seasons where there'd
be bureaucratic minutiae of
rebuilding King's Landing.
STEPHENSON: Well, I didn't get that job. But I do, yeah I
do see the...In that and other television
series I sometimes see things that my
initial reaction is that I'm looking at
lazy writing, but I don't know if it's...I
suspect what it really is is the
showrunner saying, 'Such and such thing
needs to happen 35 minutes into this episode, or else.' And so
then everything has to be rearranged to
make that occur. And so that's, I think,
when you sometimes see a character
suddenly do something that's out of
character, which I think
accounts for a lot of the dissatisfaction
that people felt when with the the last
part of that TV series, kind of rushing
it to a conclusion.